et bienvenue à concarneau l'abri de
cornouaille kong quernec ça se dit en
breton concarneau une des plus jolies
perles du collier qui enchâsse le
finistère je parle du collier des ports
et de tous ces paysages merveilleux ici
concarneau et bien c'est un port de
pêche absolument extraordinaire c'est
même le premier port de pêche thoniers
de france et c'est le troisième pour la
pêche fraîche alors nous verrons ici bas
et qu'il ya comme partout un petit peu
la crise et pas seulement d'ailleurs
dans la pêche mais aussi de la
construction navale
nous arrivons d'ailleurs à concarneau au
moment où vient d'être signé une
convention qui met un terme à deux ans
de conflit entre les armateurs thoniers
et les marins un thonier nous verrons
aussi beaucoup d'autres choses puisque
c'est un port de pêche et bien il ya un
musée de la pêche que nous allons voir
tout à l'heure et puis nous avons rendez
vous avec un grand navigateur olivier de
kersauzon qui à quelques encablures
d'ici prépare son nouveau bateau enfin
agrandit son bateau à 27 mètres et nous
parlerons bien sûr de tout cela avec lui
et comme la première fois que je suis
venu à concarneau
ouh là là j'avais une douzaine d'années
c'était la fête des filets bleus
c'est quelque chose que nous évoquerons
parce que ça a laissé un grand souvenir
ici ça existe toujours d'ailleurs la
fête des filets bleus et j'étais revenu
aussi à concarneau pour un concert des
tri yann et tout près de là bas il y
avait les harpes des triskell les crises
qu'elles que nous allons entendre tout
au long de cette émission avec aussi
quelques morceaux de musique du groupe
sory sow n'est rien du
voilà d'abord les tris kent
[Applaudissements]
r
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
le
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
vous
mais
[Musique]
en fait des filets bleus dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure a eu 87 ans l'été
dernier
presque un record pour une fête
traditionnelle de cette importance et
cet été c'était les traditions
portugaise qui étaient invités et on
découvrait pas d'autres rudesse des
travailleurs de la mer dans une autre
région d'europe
la fête des filets bleus et fils et un
en bleu pour tromper la sardine donc
pour la paix chez la fête des filets
bleus
ce fut à l'origine en 1905 une fête de
bienfaisance était organisée par les
artistes parce que et la sardine avait
quitté la région alors misère pour les
pêcheurs misère pour les ouvrières des
conserveries misère pour tous ceux qui à
concarneau où vivaient de la sardine la
sardine revint pourtant on a compté ici
avant guerre jusqu'à 30 de conserverie
sardinerie et puis bon les pêcheurs de
concarneau s'organisèrent pour la pêche
hauturière au large en pleine mer est
aujourd'hui la sardine n'est plus qu'une
toute petite activité et il ne reste qu
une conserverie une consigne sardinerie
c'est la conserverie gonidec aux
mouettes d'arvor que nous allons voir
maintenant
[Musique]
et
c
bonjour daniel gonidec
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que presque plus
de sardines ici je me suis fait
reprocher puisqu'il ya encore une
conserverie ou est ce que vous achetez
vous servir ici pour le coup la criée
tous les matins oui il ya encore des
pêcheurs oui on en a pas forcément tous
les matins mais
on est quand même très longtemps combien
de bateaux qui pêchent a servi à 7,8
taiwo à bord des soeurs de la corne d'or
dans la taille de la boîte
finalement là bas tu feras des passants
gros sinon il ya plus de place pour lui
je quitte sa faim d'importance on en met
davantage on peut faire deux boîtes à
saint-affrique à 7
finalement c'est bien écrit alors ce qui
est étonnant c'est que cette conserverie
là elle est née en 1959 alors que tout
les conserveries de sardines fermer
certains diables et pourquoi
bon ya plusieurs causes à la fermeture
des usines
oui dharma pourquoi vous vous avez créé
à votre père votre beau père a créé
cette conserverie alors que les autres
firmes est ce parce que les croyait il
croyait à quoi une meilleure qualité
qualité voilà fait un produit de luxe
non c'est pas du luxe
c'est du haut de gamme mais un prix très
abordable oui ça se vend à peu près
combien 950 une boîte de sardines à
l'huile d'olive
est normale chez via el mundo vu mais on
nous vend au prix dans les supermarchés
et ça marche pas bien
oui et tout est fait à la main alors si
c'est ça qui explique le coût le coût
différent quoi oui c'est pour cela
demain d'après l'omb ce qu'ont fait les
viscères et on est fait à la main suite
elle effritait les sécher est fait dans
de l'huile elle est écoutée toute une
nuit
et puis on en boîte
ouais
m
[Musique]
et
e
[Musique]
et si je mange des baux sardine est ce
que je vais manger toute la journée
non
comment on fait
c'est la différence serait pas réglé
heures c'est qu'avec vos sardines passe
très bien les digèrent très bien
merci daniel gonidec et maintenant on va
les voir la grande pêche à concarneau
[Musique]
l'homme que nous allons rencontrer
maintenant c'est non seulement le
responsable de l'armement d'hellemmes
très connu ici grande expérience de la
pêche depuis 45
mais c'est aussi le responsable de tous
les armements ici connaît la pêche par
coeur et on a beaucoup de questions à
lui poser parce que la crise du poisson
est là
[Musique]
j'aime bien les élèves vous est présenté
je sais bien que vous êtes président de
l'armement d'hellemmes
oui mais vous êtes aussi vous avez des
responsabilités dont le port conseil de
surveillance pour des armateurs aussi
est en fait il s'agit du conseil
portuaire c'est ça pour avoir une idée
c'est combien de bateaux ici à pau car
nous c'est la flottille thonière c'est
une bonne trentaine de thoniers
océaniques les bateaux de pêche ses
trente cinq chalutiers hauturiers
d'environ 35 mètres 1000 chevaux c'est
aussi 35 artisans de 24 mètres environ
avec des puissances de l'ordre de 600
chevaux
et puis bien sûr et puis une petite aux
artisans alors il peut tirer artisanale
qu'est-ce qui a fait que concarneau
prennent cette dimension de premier port
thonier de troisième port hauturier
français et je sens monter vision de la
sortie de surmonter une sorte de
sardines c'est quand même la guerre de
39-45 qui a fait se replier pas mal par
matters boulonnais et outre l'orienter à
concarneau pendant la guerre et ils ont
découvert là je dirais
une pépinière de marins qui est en fait
la vraie force de concarneau oui c'est
on a une idée de la population marin et
seniors et le port emploie à peu près
2000 naviguant à la pêche c'est quand
même important
on parle beaucoup de la crise du poisson
pourtant moi je consomme de plus en plus
de poissons et je pense que les français
sont comme moi qu'est ce qui explique
cette crise va la crise je crois qu'elle
est allée double il y a d'abord
essentiellement un problème de
ressources en ce qui concerne les
espèces de faune plus espèces démersales
hewitt et sa wii bien c'est à dire qu'il
y ait en fait un effort de paix je
trouve important par rapport à ce que la
ressource peut donner et je crois que
il faudra y passer pareille ça vous êtes
un homme battre votre couple quelque
part un peu c'est certain mais il faut
reconnaître qu'il ya trop de bateaux sur
sur la mer et que c'est ensemble de
navires et trop conséquente pour ce que
la ressource peut donner ce qui est pas
forcément de forcément vrai dans toutes
les espèces parce que par exemple dans
les espèces pélagiques il ya un bon
équilibre et il n'ya pas apparemment de
problèmes de quantité
pour le moment notre réseau l'autre
raison héroïne de marché je crois qu on
a été pendant très longtemps à l'abri
des importations à cause des coûts du
transport mais aujourd'hui traversé
l'atlantique ça ne coûte pas très cher 5
seafrance fret avion pour du poisson
frais et même aujourd'hui nous
ressentons le poids des importations en
provenance des usa mais bien sûr aussi
tous les pays nordiques essentiellement
à l écosse et la norvège et l'islande
alors est ce que c'est une situation
provisoire ou bien bien comment vous
voyez-vous l'avenir
est ce que ça peut s'améliorer dans le
métier nous avons connu déjà un certain
nombre de crises et je crois que un
cycle est ainsi qui est de l'ordre d'une
douzaine d'années on a déjà repéré dans
les temps passés
mais je crois que le creux que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui n'a jamais été
aussi profond et que les entreprises les
plus endettés ont vraiment le beaucoup
de mal à s'en sortir
merci pierre yves de m alors pensons
aussi aux femmes de concarneau
souvenez-vous à noirmoutier on a rappelé
que les femmes de concarneau et de
douarnenez aller là-bas aller là bas au
moment de la sardine il ya quelques
années de ça bien sûr aller là-bas
travailler ici et continue encore à
travailler à la criée
jadis c'était dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles aujourd'hui ça
c'est sans doute amélioré mais on a va
voir justement une de ces femmes qui
travaillent de nuit à la criée aux
poissons
valérie rtl a suivi une de ces femmes
katia
à concarneau quand la ville dort le port
s'éveille il est 23 heures c'est l'heure
où les bateaux rentrer au port pour
décharger le produit de plusieurs jeux
de pêche
à terre les dockers les attendent des
hommes et des femmes comme katia qui
prennent leur service quand les autres
se couche katia et filles de dockers
elle a repris ce travail de nuit pour
offrir ses journées à ses trois enfants
et ça consiste à trier soit la
langoustine les petites et grosses des
casses et les noirs un bémol à mettre
des caisses sympa tout ça parfois c'est
une par une donc ça dure des heures par
moments parfois est autrement si le
poisson façon ce que ce soit mis en
ligne pour aller dans les magasins de
marine le matin
c'est très dur parce que c'est des
conditions quand même debout dans le
froid l'hiver dans ma tasse à gérer
quand même comme on a eu les ibères
dernier il a très durement
quand même les doigts comme un poster et
chaufferie fait quand même les
mouvements aussi de la glace mais c'est
quand même le froid les rhumatismes
gagnent beaucoup d'argent
c'est à dire qu'on est payés au smig et
une prime suivant les bateaux on vient
des mensualités donc on n'a pas le même
régime qui lie à les leurs avant avant
les bons mois
7000 francs et les mauvaises mais les
mauvais c'est quand il y avait pas de
bateau c'était dans la limite de quatre
mille c'est pas dur de partir le soir de
la maison est très dur alors là c'est
très dur très très dur de partir quand
il fait froid on est bien on a passé une
bonne soirée quand il pleut dehors quand
il fait froid
ainsi il ya des jours à bien tous fait
un appartement
moi je préfère faire ça que d'être
vendeuse ça c'est très dur a quand même
très dur compliqué
moi c'est à dire que ce que je préfère
c'est la liberté quand même
on est là la journée avec les gosses
meurent même on a besoin de n'importe
quoi
on est la chose que trans c'est pas
possible
ma mère disait toujours ma fille je ne
veux pas que tu sois dockers disait
toujours ma mère je veux pas que tu sois
dockers si elle voyait la peau je
reviendrai pas
depuis quelques années il ya ici une
crise du thon en général et puis surtout
une crise du thon tropical
alors j'ai eu ça dans les journaux et
notamment dans ouest france sous la
plume de roger cougot qui est un grand
spécialiste des affaires maritimes et
ancien marin pêcheur lui même et il ya
eu un compromis l'a récemment entre
armateurs et marin je vais voir
exactement avec lui comment ça s'est
passé
roger cougot merci de nous accueillir
dans vos locaux d'ouest france à
concarneau
je vais vous voir parce que vous êtes un
spécialiste de la pêche soutenez la
rubrique pêche à ouest-france la
rubrique maritime peut-être même ses
plus larges et nous arrivons nous au
moment où il ya un conflit qui se
termine enfin ya un compromis à propos
du taux du thon tropical et comme
concarneau c'est le premier port
français du thon ça nous intéresse de
savoir pourquoi ils eussent conflit
d'abord et maintenant pourquoi ce
compromis
c'est un conflit à double niveau un
conflit d'abord d'ordre économique et à
dimension mondiale et ensuite un conflit
d'ordre social avec un changement
radical dans le type de rémunération et
des conditions des marins à bord les
équipages depuis déjà un certain nombre
d'années depuis 1979 avait les
conditions de rémunération et de travail
très particulière dans la mesure où il
avait obtenu contrairement à ce qu'il se
fait pas tout ailleurs dans les pêches
y compris d'ailleurs autres font dans
les pays de l'est où les pêcheurs sont
toujours payés au prorata du prix du
bois sont là les pêcheurs de thon
avaient obtenu 79 un changement de
système grâce à toute une activité
syndicale menée pas assujettir l'époque
et après une grève très dure dans le
golfe de guinée
le système avec des emplacements la bête
était celui d'une prime à la tonne péché
alors du coup les marins rue leur époque
d'or absolument et par ce système là
automatiquement au fur et à mesure que
les captures était annoncée à bord des
navires dans l'océan indien ou dans le
golfe de guinée
les marins et surtout leurs épouses à
terre pouvez calculer le gars j'allais
dire
al ahmar et enfin ou même la semaine la
limite ce qui était quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire il complet pour
l'économie locale à concarneau aussi
puisque tout le commerce local
bénéficier de ces salaires effectivement
qui était assez substantiel là comme
tout a changé
voilà de leurs oeuvres à la crise
économique
effectivement avec la sphère du dauphin
et avec également il faut le dire la
concurrence aussi d'autres pays qui ont
armé des flops tenir importante
venezuela par exemple mais aussi du sur
le plan asiatique avec la corée est vrai
que le japon est également les
transferts qui se sont offertes niveau
de la transformation du produit par
exemple le temps est beaucoup plus mais
on conserve aujourd'hui en thaïlande à
tel point que des conserveurs des grands
groupes de 'conserver' américains ont
transfo maintenant mettre leurs poissons
à boîte en thaïlande
bien sûr à des coûts beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins onéreux alors problème
mondial que vous l'avez dit mais comme
le marin aux quarts de ces différences
ces différents aspects ont contraint les
producteurs et les armateurs de ton à
revoir toutes les conditions en dire on
ne peut plus supporter cette concurrence
au niveau du marché
on ne peut plus non plus supporter les
coûts de transport très très très très
lourd du poisson il faut donc revoir
complètement le système et on a demandé
aux marins d'être moins nombreux à bord
des bateaux et de deux de réduire leur
salaire et c'était donc une longue
longue bataille deux ans de conflit en
fait qui vient de s'achever
d'une façon parcellaire parce que toute
l'afrique et il n'est pas concerné
par la signature d'une commande nouvelle
convention collective qui aujourd'hui
j'allais dire correspond à une sorte de
régression sociale entre guillemets pour
les marins puissent qu'ils abandonnent
leur système de salaire à la prune péché
pour revenir un salaire qui est indexée
sur le chiffre d'affaires du thonier ce
qui fait que grosso modo pour un haras
qui gagne il ya deux ans autour de 25
mille francs
pardon des 259 en de 250 mille francs
dans l'année 5200 thing ça se ramène
aujourd'hui autour de seize 16 à 17
millions de centimes
[Musique]
e
dans une partie du monde dans le
pacifique est et seulement dans cette
région là le ton est pêché en même temps
que des dauphins qui sont capturés de
façon accidentelle mais dans des
proportions qui peuvent être parfois
importantes mais encore une fois dans
cette zone là dans le pacifique
est ce les protecteurs des animaux
dénonce enfin les associations
écologistes des états unis sont partis
en guerre d'une façon très très forte
contre ces pratiques et ont réussi à
obtenir de la part des conserveurs
américain un boycott de ces produits
pêchés avec les dauphins
la méthode américaine absolument
pardonner ce sont les américains qui
brillent quand on fait deux morts par
des thoniers senneurs américain est au
nombre des victimes devant ce boycott
plus de débouchés pour ce ton là et
vendeurs se sont tournés naturellement
vers à peu près leur seule issue c'est
peut-être le marché européen et l'italie
notamment mais aussi l'espagne et on
était contraint et forcé de vendre ce
poisson la très bas prix sur l'europe ce
qui a entraîné tout de suite une
concurrence extrêmement dur pour les
pêcheurs français et espagnols qui
travaillent sur cette même espèce mais
dans d'autres secteurs et qui eux ne
pêche pas de dauphin
c'est là le paradoxe c'est que les
thoniers bretons sont victimes d'une
pratique qui leur est complètement
étrangère biensir l'écoutent
retour à la poésie al concarneau avec
d'abord une deuxième morceau des tris
kane et puis après eh bien nous allons
voir le peintre jean le merdy
jacentes sais-tu payson un tassement
ah mais quel but aisés qui sont gt
quelle influence a carrément
sais-tu résout
av
bouzou
ten days mans s'est fait plaisir
elle m'a
et zou
préserver ses tubes maison or ce pays
par ce mécanisme s'échanger des canuts
à gagner
à nouveau
de ce fait c'est tout
mes mains
le fait
jospeh ses tubes et zou
c'était
hilarité
mais comme d'affreux ben dahoua carnot
sandero
l'un d'eux
7e
sais tu
nous sommes est
m
c'est dur
mais
bah mise en musique par les triskell les
frères café d en bas c'était un poème de
young guernic qui au temps où il était
aimé gré à new york en 67
baptisé à fantômes je ne suis qu'un
fantôme
moi qui me croyais si vivant je suis un
fantôme puisque personne ne sait ce que
je suis pas josé résumé son poème
c'était au temps où il était mieux
régner yorkais ils s'ennuient évidemment
beaucoup de la bretagne alors avec les
fainéants on est à concarneau est pas de
si loin vous êtes de marestaing et
presse après de bresse le relecq-kerhuon
c'est la rentrée pour gaza les bras ça
coûtait et ça fait combien 20 ans plus
de 20 ans le gouvernement 70 la
télévision japonaise est venue il ya
quelques jours et est alors ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'elle a regardé voir
peu avec une minutie voilà où nous
l'avions testé traître est venu ils ont
les ont filmés donc sont enregistrés
deux morceaux puissants surtout filmer
tout l'intérieur de ces arts tous les
systèmes électroniques
tout tout tout tout était très très très
très très polis qu'ils espionnaient la
norme c'est qu'il s'est vraiment poser
des questions tout le monde se poser les
questions qu'est-ce qu'il faut parce
qu'ils ont passé près de deux heures a
subi exactement tous les ans destaillac
là elle existe déjà dit hier le dr paye
à wall celtic g des bombardes et binious
causera également alors oui on est
bombardé japon les bzh également été
sorti c'est difficile la harpe
comme tous les âges ce que ça vient
enfin et athènes après beaucoup m'ont
appris beaucoup et quand un tout petit
peu mais après ça devant lui comme la
guitare n'importe quel instrument les
personnes qui sont plus
j'irai pas doué cepal 40 terme qui sont
plus à l'aise sur cet instrument
gg si tu veux le corps de 10 passant je
sais très bien que je suis pas doué pour
ça que donc ce site parc nous donne à
queiroz on va essayer que ça marchera
jamais l'europe
il marchera jamais le cuir arrive jamais
merci
l'histoire de la peinture est très
injuste je trouve avec concarneau
oui on parle beaucoup de l'école de
pont-aven de leur chef de file gauguin
de maurice denis etc
et on ne parle pas suffisamment de ceux
qui ont beaucoup aidés cette ville alors
il ya un peintre que j'ai vu moi la
galerie des orfèvres à paris qui depuis
42 ans
la ville de concarneau somport surtout
on voit à travers sa peinture
l'évolution de ce port alors je vais
aller le voir mais ça ça cette
intéressante mallet cet homme là il ne
peint que ce qu'il voit la nature le
port et comme il ne veut pas être
dérangé ne pas se mettre sur le quai
avec son chevalet pour que les gens
viennent voir ce qu'il fait mais il se
met dans sa voiture et voilà son atelier
son atelier pour peindre le réel
en marchant le merdy
en plus
bonjour dans le vernis
alors qu'est ce que vous êtes en train
de faire je referai un peu plus pas tout
à fait du tout si je n'ai jamais cru que
ce sont des entrelacs rival entremêlés
vous avez pas le parent vous depuis
longtemps et puis au moins 43 ans a
avoué au départ je déposerai suite
[Musique]
m
j'ai téléphoné à voilà une des mac au
québec les bateaux en bois beaucoup et
beaucoup ça vous inspirer beaucoup la
voile plus jeune c'était le dernier il
ya les voyez que je suis différent
je fais beaucoup la dd des couleurs de
bois le formidable et bleu outremer des
jeunes des rousses et orange était très
beau pour son 20e et dernier
et qu'est ce qui vous inspire
aujourd'hui dans dans le port non à
concarneau concarneau bateau le le port
les bateaux mais autrement plus
pittoresques comme dans le temps que la
ville est lui trop grande dans les rues
moins de charme dans les rues danton et
les ruptures les rebelles donnant sur la
mer de très beaux que les maisons
avaient plus de cachet que nombre trouve
à part les bateaux puis le tibet selon
elle accompagnait belhocine c'est bien
d'elle
nos moeurs
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on appelait le groupe de
concarneau quotidienne des pâtres cette
époque j'étais un groupe mais je vais
d'abord c'était jean 1881 il ya eu je
voulais y avait un coq à nos côtés aux
beaux-arts et puis café ni l écoute des
amis se font mais un petit groupe comme
ça du soul et j'avais le professeur vie
des deux appareils était né avec lui
mais mais c'était vraiment une terre
bénie pour les pins dans les comptes
mène pas loin d'un potentat 12 km
seulement les protéger c'est pour les
police menée par farid rival est pas là
bas coût de cette école c'est pareil
prenez comme d'antan les patates à
appuyer s'il faut les transporter nos
thèses mais nombre de voitures mais il
ya peu de peintres talent et de sa
nature mais il y avait un petit train
entre plantes invasives comme le surcoût
pour les affaires tous ceux qui quand on
histoires de gauguin par exemple ici
c'est vrai ce qu'on raconte
j'ai fait quelques essais amoché la
jambe cassée la jambe et une histoire
perdu et je connais pas l'histoire mais
dû gifler un gosse et le gaucher n'est
pas son père je plaide me casser la
jambe
ah ouais quand je me remémore de sauf
conduit à rendre beaucoup plus tard
merci jean le merdy de nous avoir reçu
dans votre atelier est de continuer
aussi la tradition des peintres dans
cette région au carnot pont-aven le
pouldu etc et maintenant on va voir
justement gwenaëlle bolloré qui connaît
bien l'histoire de cette ville et qui
connaît bien l'histoire de ces peintres
aussi
[Musique]
je
non
et
bolouri ce nom est connu en france et
dans le monde entier comme celui d'un
grand capitaine d'industrie
d'ailleurs le groupe vincent bolloré a
son siège social à quimper nice n'est
pas vincent bolloré nous allons
rencontrer maintenant c'est gwen à l
bolloré son nom est grâce à lui nous
allons faire un petit tour vous ont
flâné dans la généalogie d'une famille
issue de concarneau
quand jérôme bonnell bolloré jours merci
de nous recevoir et toujours soit pas
tout au plus 12 accueil messi parce
qu'au fond les bolloré c'est une très
ancienne famille de concarneau même si
elle a été on après s'installer ailleurs
absolument
g parce que mon arrière grand père a
fait des campagnes en chine comme celle
aux jeunes de marigny là il à son
bouquet il a laissé un journal de bord
qui valait la peine d'être édité élan
j'ai essayé de revenir en arrière et je
suis remonté jusqu'en 715 donc depuis
715 les bolloré était des concarnois
remet il était peut-être plusieurs jeux
dizaines de générations avant ghosn et
le bolloré pourquoi y at il une ville
close à concarneau
à quoi ça rime est pas ça servait et
bien c'est une place fortifiée
vous savez à l'époque ça se voit ça se
voit et alors là il avait la chance de
pouvoir voir un pont-levis et quand même
augmenter le
l'efficacité du dispositif alors il y
avait des anglais qui est elle a assuré
que les anglais pas remplies glénan ont
été occupées par les anglais en règle et
non c'est à 9000 de concarneau donc
concarneau c'était à châteaufort c'est
ça et puis il y avait aussi la ligue les
protestants 1
et alors ça c'est un petit peu avant il
y avait beaucoup de protestants montagne
la majorité catholique bien entendu et
comme les protestants se trouvait très
seul ils s'étaient regroupés ici
ici dans la ville kerlavic causé un
certain moment il ma mémoire la flash un
petit peu je peux pas vous dire quel âne
exactement mais un certain moment ils
ont occupé la ville close et assiégée
par les catholiques qui est elle était
de l'autre côté sur derrière le pont de
vic voilà derrière le polonais
[Musique]
toute la ville en a parlé longtemps
toute la ville en parle encore mais la
sphère de l'église saint coeur de marie
bat commence à lasser l'opinion
une centaine de personnes une
association veut empêcher la destruction
de cette église qui a été très frappé
par l'ouragan 87
mais il faut dire que la destruction de
ce gros édifice arrangerait peut-être un
peu la municipalité comme l'évêché
enquête valérie heures tél
à concarneau le cinéma le vox jo depuis
plusieurs années le même film la messe
horaires des séances le samedi soir et
le dimanche matin
le tout devant un public de fidèles qui
se plaint de ce que le bruit des
fauteuils gêne le recueillement
[Musique]
oh
à
harrison
la communauté chrétienne du centre ville
de concarneau a dû fuir son église
vieille de 60 ans devenu trop grande
trop froide est trop dangereuse depuis
l'ouragan de 1987
on peut visiter l'église elle est fermée
mais je vous amène
monsieur le curé on découvre l'intérieur
de cette église qui est à l'abandon
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé elle est
indépendant enfin c'est à dire qu'on a
évacué tout ce qui pouvait être sauvé
donc les strates des chefs du mobilier
mais le reste donc est à l'abandon
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle n'a pas été
restaurée à la suite de l'ouragan
ça coûtait beaucoup de trop cher par de
restaurer fortune une autre église sont
beaucoup plus fonctionnel plus adapté à
la liturgie d'aujourd'hui
moi je ne la trouve pas
bale n'est pas réussie n'a pas d'oeuvre
d'art devant ya comme un petit travail
et un que quelques micros mais qu'on va
pouvoir
donc de récupérer jean paul et les
installer dans la nouvelle non pas
forcément non non
oh
et
philippe le coz vous avez fondé
l'association des amis de l'église de
concarneau pourquoi vous voulez il a
sauvé cette église dont elle fait partie
du patrimoine local
elle a maintenant donné même si elle
n'est pas très bien ils datent que du
début du siècle elle a un petit peu
donner son identité à la ville elle
vient bien en complément elle vient bien
en complément de la ville close et je
crois que c'est important effectivement
que concarneau garde sept éléments de
son patrimoine
sk la part est-il un petit peu bâtard en
france a dit oui tout à fait il faut
reconnaître que l'architecte est en
partie chercher une aspiration exotiques
et ayant utilisé les techniques locales
c'est-à-dire le granit lardoise on
arrive à un résultat un petit peu
incongru mais ça fait l'originalité de
l'édifice
elle est là je la trouve assez hideuse
sauf quand on arrive par mer où c'est
vrai que ça ressemble à sainte-sophie
constantinople mais autrement de près
les poches d'eau gelée que je lis j'ai
vu les premiers offices là dedans alors
je trouve que ça serait dommage vaut
mieux le restaurer mais celle là on peut
la réparer ça coûte cher ça fait encore
plus cher de l'eure turinoise je pense
qu'il faut la démolir parce que tout le
monde mais pour la démolition
mais bon
nous on voudrait une solution très
rapidement le vent vient de se lever sur
concarneau mais ça n'est rien ça n'est
vraiment rien à côté de ce qui s'est
passé en octobre 87
[Musique]
quand quelqu'un qui se souvient bien de
cet ouragan de 87
c'est olivier de kersauson est avec nous
et olivier qui est venu nous voir
d'ailleurs c'est gentil ce qui est en
train de faire la finition de son bateau
de 27 m qui va faire le tour du monde
bientôt
olivier a vécu cette tempête etc vous en
connaissez des tempêtes mais là c'était
quelque chose là ça ressemblait à un
cyclone un point de vue température que
machete en j'aurais dû partir à la baule
pour la baule dakar seront là avec mon
bateau poulin et puis le routeur et
monique parent pas il ya un truc qui
arrive donc dans le golfe de gascogne
qui est panel je comprends pas et je dis
à ton demain j'attends demain surmonté
de la baule en voiture sur west et en
arrivant juste à la verticale d'ici quoi
sur la bretelle à quatre voies c'était
la cité le cyclone c'est que non moins
réussi à remonter vers le nord parce
qu'on était le vent d'ouest et qu'on
était sur la partie droite de la quatre
voies donc les arbres tombaient de
l'autre côté mais on voyait passer
je voyais pas céder tous les souvenirs
je vais passer les poules aise qu'est ce
qui se passe ces oiseaux ce volatile n'a
pas l'habitude de voler avec tant
d'élégance qui est en fait ils volaient
pas il est emmené par le mans et les
débris végétaux et on s'est arrêté sur
concarneau à la boîte se lance dans
tiens on va voir ce qui se passe on
descend de la voiture il est chaud mais
pour moi ça m'a rappelé les cycles ans
que j'avais connu un nouvel quelques
nuits où l'on voudra pacifique il y
avait le côté d'une grande violence
et en plus le la bretagne entière était
dans le noir d'habitude en roulant la
nuit ou en arrivant sur les ports on
voit des halos laon voyez pas une
lumière alors qu'olivier où en est votre
charal ce
à lui le bateau on dit une bête des
mères à 25 m way dans le char alba il
sort de chantier le le 18 on est à l'eau
et le 19 dans quelques jours quelques
jours le 19 ans sera à la mer et en
entraînement jusqu'au départ du tour du
monde en 80 jours
oui 80 jours donc on va reparler et puis
vous prendrai le départ a priori vers le
mois de janvier que partie à partir du
15 janvier c'est un record un art force
à venir ont choisi le créneau météo qui
après une fois partie on pourra pas
choisir tout le monde à faire dans les
80 jours météorologiques à gérer et on
part donc il faut avoir un créneau météo
qui permet de bien dégager de la
bretagne de rejoindre le cap finistère
rapidement et d'accrocher des alizés
lors des côtes d'afrique doit bien sûr
qu'on est quand même une situation
météorologique à peu près organisé alors
ça s'est jamais fait en 80 jours quelle
était votre record au premier tour du
monde
moi sur en solitaire j'ai fait en
multicoques 125 jours mais avec 42 jours
de calme c'est ça que je croyais en
vercors parce que on peut investir
préparer se battre on est quand même à
la merci de
du temps on fait de la technique ont
fait du carbone en fait c'est toi du
booker quand même normal c'est de l'
aventure qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous
avez à prouver ce que vous l'avez déjà
fait ça bon mais pas battu le record
c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui vous êtes
vous êtes moi je suis en entrevue c'est
moi qui avais le record il a débattu
après c'est moi qui avais le record mais
si je vous dis pour vous mettre à l'aise
qua non non non je sais que vous aviez
une reculade étendu mais qu'est ce que
vous avez à prouver sur la mer vous y
être un homme d'écriture un homme
d'esprit de culture un homme de radio
comme moi d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qui vous fait à nouveau vous
précipiter sur une embarcation de celle
ci moi j'ai fait de l'écriture pour
bouffer de la radio pour bouffer bref
pour bouffer pour pour vivre pour être
heureux gfa navigation j'ai fait
navigation et xavier mathias vraiment le
reste le point vous fait dire que bon
vous êtes pauvre sûreté enfin pas tout à
nolan on sait que dans la dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui bois foncé paraison
génétique
j'ai besoin d espace et de liberté en
l'espace y en a de moins en moins et la
liberté à terre
vraiment vous arrêtez votre voiture
c'est une zone bleue vous allumez la
clope il ya quatre personnes qui fait
sur vous et les grosses têtes airtel
amiral tout ça c'est une aventure aussi
de quelques parents aventure
radiophonique dans la vie où on a réussi
en 12 ans à avoir les plus grosses parts
de marché c'est ce côté là c'est ce
challenge là qui est marrant c'est dans
un monde où tout le monde se bagarrent
d'aller faire la bagarre sur ce point là
mais pour moi ça me fait pas marrer vous
pouvez bien sûr que les autres qui se
marre mais vous aussi sauvé mais n'ont
pas tellement mais y avait le béa le bon
côté quand même des choses que moi je
suis dit s'ils suivent retombe et que
tout ce que ça peut représenter
de qualité de défauts mais de qualité
surtout parce que choisir secure c'est
pas de l'argent qui sont les pieds quand
on voit l'argent qu'on aura gagné avec
rtl j'aurais gagné 11 en rire les autres
j'ai tellement de gens qui gagnent leur
argent leur faisant de la peine
ça m'aidera plus tard
que me disait quand il s'appelait déjà
monsieur de la palisse et bien le
poisson n'est jamais venu tout seul dans
le filet des pêcheurs il a fallu aller
en chercher avec des bateaux et ici nous
sommes à concarneau devant un des grands
de la construction navale à des grands
de la construction navale qui a commencé
en 1964 c'est le chantier des frères
piriou alors c'est très bizarre parce
que ce chantier s'est développée à cause
d'une commande importante de à
l'exportation c'était un une commande de
quatorze bateaux ou rue un armement
libyens et mauritaniens et puis alors
quand ils ont vu ça les gens de
concarneau ce sont 10 mai sont bien dans
ce chantier là on va leur faire
construire nos propres bateaux nos
propres chalut alors on va voir comment
tout ça s'est passé et surtout comment
va la situation aujourd'hui dans la
construction navale à concarneau
bonjour jacques piriou alors vous êtes
le directeur général des chantiers
piriou fondée par votre père et par
votre frère une curiosité comme ça
combien de bateaux ont été construits
ici
si nous avons construit 160 bateaux 160
bateaux alors quel genre de bateaux de
toutes tailles de 25 à 60 mètres
chalutiers et thoniers senneurs ah oui
les grands l'aller les grands thoniers
senneurs qui navigue actuellement large
et prête africaine et seychelloises
et puis vous vous diversifiez aussi des
cours on essaye de se diversifier en
faisant du remorqueur de la barre du
navire à passagers alors justement
pensez bien que il ya une crise de la
pêche qu'il faut bien appeler comme ça
donc il doit y avoir une crise de la
construction navale
effectivement il ya une crise de la
construction navale notre notre force un
petit peu c'est d'essayer de trouver des
marchés en réparation jeu comme la crème
des moyens de
de faire de grosses réparations ici est
un fardeau j'ai cherché des marchés à
l'exportation à l'exportation qui
achètent des bateaux de pêche concarnois
travaillons beaucoup pour l'afrique de
l'ouest est aussi si on peut considérer
ça comme exportations nous avons un
marché actuellement sur la polynésie
française
et
[Musique]
elena venir vous voyez l'avenir c'est
les gros ou grosses unités où est ce
qu'on va aller vers plus petit que je
dirai à taille plus humaine et peut-être
aussi pour sauvegarder le poisson un
petit peu dans des bateaux de 20 mètres
connaissent des difficultés actuellement
les bateaux de 35 dates ne marche pas
beaucoup mieux
disons que
il ya une période à passer de 2 3 ans
ensuite on devrait voir un peu plus
clair
eh bien merci jacques culioli
[Musique]
là
e
[Musique]
quand kersauson voit sauter des dauphins
autour de son bateau quand ils voient
des baleines c'est un spectacle
extraordinaire et puis aussi quand on
les voit dans les aquariums par exemple
tout à l'heure vous les verrez dans le
musée de la pêche et bien ça apprend
beaucoup de choses sous la faute sur la
faune sous marine
il ya une autre façon de regarder un peu
cette faune sous-marine de regarder les
poissons leur espèce leurs différentes
tailles et bien c'est de les naturaliser
j'avoue que j'ai pas beaucoup de goût
pour la naturalisation
mais enfin il faut respecter le travail
des hommes il faut surtout voir à quoi
ça sert on va entrer là j'ai un
spécialiste
et
[Musique]
un peu
e
dans la presse bonjour vous êtes en
train de faire quoi en train de
naturaliser une petite sole de roche
entraîneur c'est à dire que vous enlevez
la peau bruit ceci obligé d'enlever la
poule et c'est la peau en fait qui va
servir à reconstituer le poisson tout à
fait l'interface radio estimant que la
pohdh authentique qui peut donc je vous
avoue que bon ça mais ça me dégoûte un
peu la peau de poisson à chair de
poisson les arêtes de poisson cinq ans
est mort mais alors quel est l'intérêt
de votre affaire je pense que l'intérêt
de la nation justement c'est de voir le
détail de voir le détail et de bien
comprendre ce qu'est un poisson comment
le reconnaître
par exemple la daurade alors là deraedt
c'est très intéressant parce que celle
ci c'est une espèce de daurade et vous
avez justement à détails
oui toutefois montré oui c'est une une
dorade royale et une gueule pavé appelée
aussi ruelle pavée par ici et quand on
voit son sa dentition sa denture plus
tôt on s'aperçoit tout de suite envie
c'est comme à paris on comprend bien
envie de nous oui c'est des pavés pour
elle pour écraser les les coquillages
d'un côté donc la forme et fait déjà aux
mesures du du poisson plutôt de sa peau
donc là je met sa tête
et donc sur les détails ici l'encoche
pour pour la nageoire
eh oui
[Musique]
à cet appareil de quotidiens
je
[Musique]
il
e
[Musique]
mon
et
les ports français sont nombreux à voir
leur musée de la mer musée
océanographique musée de leur propre
histoire maritime
mais le musée de la pêche de concarneau
peut sûrement dire sans vexer personne
qu'il est le tout premier dans sa
catégorie
c'est à la fois comme dit gwenaëlle
bolloré le président de l'association
des amis du musée
c'est à la fois à l'instrument de
travail et une mémoire une mémoire de la
mère et de la pêche
alors nous allons rencontrer bientôt son
conservateur qui est aussi auteur de ce
musée de la pêche de ce petit livre sur
musée de la pêche
grâce à quoi je connais déjà un petit
peu de choses sur ce musée et qui est
édité chez picollec
[Musique]
j'aurais réglo j'ai trouvé formidable je
dois vous le dire parce que c'est un
musée alors quand on dit musée ça
effraie toujours un peu les gens peuvent
être monotone amusé ça peut être un peu
statique
je trouve que c'est un musée vivant
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire la pêche
est quelque chose de très vivant
oh
ouais
vous
31 ans d'existence et une spécificité
par les masses que vous avez voulu faire
s'amuse est presque unique au monde
c'est vous qui me l'avait dit ah oui sa
responsabilité peut absolument c'est
défendre très peu de la pêche uniquement
de la plage et de l'évolution des
techniques et de l'évolution des
techniques et surtout depuis enfin ces
quinze dernières années on va de plus en
plus vers l'évolution technique parce
que quand le musée a été créé c'était le
musée d'autrefois la r2 à bout du grand
père avait voilà la photo de lancer à
trèves quelques vieux objets alors que
maintenant il ya quand même une demande
du public pour voir l'explication de ce
cui c'est pédagogique on moi j'écoute et
je ne savais pas trop comment se
passaient la pêche au chalut chalut qui
raclent le fond chalut pélagique là j'ai
tout compris
j'ai compris la pêche au thon les
différentes techniques de la pêche au
thon comme empêche alan boss de la
sardine de la morue même enfin vous avez
annoncé assez bas et on essaye surtout
de le
ii représentée par on appelle des
dioramas c'est à dire des des pièces
vivante
enfin vivante pas nécessairement qui
bouge mais en action alors lorsqu'il ya
aussi de remarquables dans votre musée
c'est que c'est ici que ça se réveille
c'est un musée qui travaillent ils
travaillent pour lui même il fait des
maquettes
[Musique]
vous
oh
et
[Musique]
dubaï
m
brown
g
durée
hélas
des
j'aime me
nous allons quitté concarneau comme nous
y sommes venus à bord du bateau de
services du port et avec eux désirent
évidemment d'y revenir un jour d'y
flâner encore un jour comme kersauce on
aura envie d'y revenir à concarneau
après son tour du monde
quand il aura achevé son tour du monde
et si je vous parle de ça c'est que
justement la semaine prochaine nous
serons samedi prochain nous serons aux
sables d'olonne aux sables d'olonne pour
le départ du vendée globe challenge un
tour du monde lui aussi sans assistance
technique sans escale est un défi
différent pour les concurrents un défi
différent de celui de kersaux sont les
sables d'olonne vous savez ça ça doit sa
réputation touristique à cette
merveilleuse plage c'est alors que
parfait dans l'atlantique en plein sud
et puis il ya un autre contraste que
j'aimerais bien regarder avec vous c'est
le musée d'art moderne de la ville de
ceux des sables d'olonne contraste parce
que vous avez vu ici les figuratif deux
groupes de concarneau de pour des pannes
de concarneau et de pont-aven bien sûr
alors à samedi prochain aux sables
d'olonne mais tiens je me dis que
peut-être avez-vous des idées à nous
suggérer des idées d'itinéraires nous
bien sûr nous avons des idées mais
pourquoi vous ne manifestera y est vous
pas vos goûts alors écrivez nous à
samedi prochain
[Musique]